how did how did this come about like did
they come and
talk to you i know you're a spokesperson
but sort of just give us the back story
a little bit about that
yeah save ralph really kind of just uh
came out of the blue
um like you mentioned i have um i'm a
spokesperson for them i've done
the have a heart campaign uh in canada
last year
um and uh i've spoken out um
on you know pig gestation crates and and
a lot of different animal issues that
are near and dear to my heart
um and so donna from the humane society
international
she she emailed me and she said hey
we're working on this project
it's a short film stop motion i think
that's what it's called
it's animated but to stop motion you
know where they actually
it's actually a little model that
they're they're moving for each frame
and uh we'd love you to voice this
character a lab rat
bunny called cotton balls would you be
interested
and uh i immediately said yes
um for me it's a it's a no-brainer
because
uh cruelty-free you know the push to
bring
free free across the board for cosmetics
is a no-brainer for me um and it wasn't
until after i said yes that i actually
really understood
who all was involved and and how really
fabulous this short
was and how much work that spencer and
andy and humane society have put into it
yeah because yeah tell us about the
other yourself and other big
huge names in this campaign uh taika
directing it
worldwide as well because they're
voicing it in
many different markets right so um i
only really knew about just
the the english market which ricky
gervais who i'm a huge fan of
um he voices the journalist doing the
documentary
and then taika watidi voices ralph
um and then there's zac efron
uh olivia munn palm uh
myself uh i think that's the the
english version yeah yeah just very cool
now i want to know did you guys get to
meet each other at all i know in this
zoom world
maybe you actually got to actually see
each other no
and actually like most um most voice
over things you don't meet the other
people anyway so of all the video games
and things and voice work i've done
very very rarely are you actually in
studio with everybody else
or anybody else let alone um no i was
here in atlanta i'm in atlanta right now
i'm filming
and um so i went to a studio here i did
see
spencer the director writer producer of
it
um he was in australia so i saw him
virtually
and uh he showed me some of the
the the visuals of what i was voicing
you know i just have a little part
when you meet when you see really what
ralph's
job is you know you meet ralph first and
then you
when you find out what his job is you
you see that there's a lot of
other um bunnies in there
lined up being tested on as well so i
basically went into a sound booth and
screamed and
cried and and yelled for about 15
minutes and then
and then it was and then my part was
done yeah i mean it is it's just like
it's such a powerful
short film and it's just like you know
it adds in that humor too but like it's
so heartbreaking right like when you
watched it completely for the first time
you know what what was your gut reaction
to it
well i actually uh i got the script
first
because as an actor right you're like
give me the script so i can i can learn
my lines and really i didn't
really need to scream i really didn't
you know
have to memorize much um but it it is
heartbreaking and i think that's what's
so
effective about this um this campaign in
this film
in particular is to get the word out and
to get the awareness out
right a lot of people tune out myself
included if i see some
you know documentary some story about an
undercover which i don't know
how these people do it i i'm amazed and
just
my heart goes out to them you know
undercover people that go into
slaughter mills and things like that
it's so hard to watch
that something like lab testing would
fall into that category if you actually
show what goes on
a lot of people just kind of tune out
and then out of sight out of mind out of
you know
um and that's where something like save
ralph
being you know he's a cute cute little
bunny
and but he's he's an object right he's
not cgi
so he actually there's a there's a sense
to
when you're watching it that you're
watching this little guy as opposed to
oh that's just cgi he's made up he's
animated
you're watching him and all the detail
and i think you know the detail of all
the work and all the framing and all the
moving of
the the the figure the doll i think
comes across
and so i think that's where it
really um sticks with people more
and maybe makes them more aware because
they will watch it because even though
it's
it's hard to watch and i've heard many
people will say
it ends up hard to watch um because
people will say it really affected them
they cried or it was
you know it was it was hard to watch
because they didn't necessarily know
that that still goes on
in this day and age you know it's such
an arc archaic practice
and i myself up until you know i don't
know how many years ago didn't even know
that this still
kind of went on i didn't think about it
i just thought about oh i like this
color of mask
you know this color of eye shadow or
this shampoo
does you know wonders for my hair and i
it doesn't come with like a warning
label of you know
a bunny going this didn't blind me yay
you know uh you know cruelty free
products you now come with a little
bunny
emblem but you have you still have to
know the
yourself to know that that's what it is
and that and you have to look for it
right yeah um so that's where where save
ralph and bringing awareness that this
still goes on
um i think is so important uh because if
we manage to get it banned and managed
to get you know influential countries
like canada
in the united states where there's been
huge movement towards it
uh ban and cosmetic the testing of
cosmetics and the ingredients
the final product and the ingredients um
then it'll be so much easier for just
the everyday public to not have to think
about it
but we have to bring awareness to the
public first right no for sure and you
can contact our legislators to
get them to pass the laws and and just
for the viewers out there
is there a specific site or something
that you would like them to go to to
to join in and help is there uh i guess
just the hashtag maybe even
yeah the hashtag certainly go to humane
society international
um hsi global you know on instagram or
just google cruelty free or you know um
because every country and every state
will have their own
um you know access to to their
legislators and that sort of thing but
it's really about
um you know there is in the states right
now there is a federal bill in congress
called the
humane cosmetics act and there was a
bill and can't you know canada's looking
to pass a bill there was a bill and then
it kind of got dropped and
um so it's it's about everybody
contacting their own legislators
to get this passed through on a federal
level
um but you can get all the information
off of humane society international
google cruelty free.ca um
or look up cruelty free free.ca if
you're in canada
and you can get all the information
there and you know find out which
products already are out there there's
thousands of products already out there
um and support those products you know
it all comes down to dollars and cents
too right businesses want to make money
and
if you know if it's
it's going to take passing the
legislation to make the companies across
the board
not be able to use products i mean in
this day and age
the the animal testing was started in
the 1940s right imagine how much
the technology has changed since then
and there's already
thousands of product uh you know
ingredients out there that have already
been
tested and tried and true and you can
use them right
um and there's now like the 3d modeling
on you know
they've made human replicas of skin and
cornea
which is a lot more reliable than the
old practice of practicing on a bunny
rabbit or a guinea pig or a rat
i myself have massive i am like my eyes
are very allergic to a lot of different
cosmetics a lot of different makeup and
those ones were all tested on animals so
it didn't even
work you know for me for me personally
it didn't even work so i would much
rather have it tested on
you know uh some human skin built in a
lab
than uh or a accordia built in a lab or
the the modeling
the computer modeling that they have now
that's a lot more reliable
in 2021 than the practices that were
used in the 1940s
you